زلازل المدمره قد ياتي بعدها نمو اقتصادي
كبير مفارقه تكررت تاريخيا في العديد من
الدول ولو انها لا تكفي لتخفيف الماسى فما
سببها
[موسيقى]
الماساه الانسانيه في تركيا وسوريا تفوق
كل وصف ولا تتركوا مجالا للتفكير بالغد
الا نلحق الاقتصاديه بعد الزلازل او
الكوارث الطبيعيه تحمل بعض الامل بحسب
دراسات عده هناك خمسه عوامل ايجابيه تدفع
الاقتصادات الى تسجيل معدلات نمو
استثنائيه بعد الزلازل والكوارث الطبيعيه
الكبرى اولا التعويضات الحكوميه الحكومات
تدفع تعويضات للافراد والمؤسسات لبناء ما
تهدم وهو ما ينتج عنه نمو اقتصادي حدث ذلك
على سبيل المثال في اليابان بعد زلزال
طوكيو في 2011 لكن مقدار التعويضات يعتمد
على مدى القدره ماليه للدوله ثانيا
الانفاق على اعاده الاعمار يخلق وظائف
ويدفع بنمو الاقتصادات حدث ذلك على سبيل
المثال بعد زلزال نيبال في 2015 وزلزال
هايتي عام 2010
ثالثا فرصه لتحديث البنيه التحتيه غالبا
ما تكون عمليه اعاده الاعمار فرصه لاعاده
تاهيل البنيه التحتيه بشكل افضل والبناء
بتقنيات تحمي من الكوارث البيئيه مثل ما
حدث بالابنيه التي شيدت باليابان بعد
زلزال كوبي في عام
رابعا قدوم الزائرين من المفارقات ان
العديد من المدن التي تعرضت لكوارث طبيعيه
شهدت زياده في السياحه وتفسير ذلك تردد
اسم المدينه بكثافه في الاعلام وحشيه
الزوار لمعاينه ما جرى
تحديث القوانين تضع الحكومات قوانين جديده
وصارمه للبناء خصوصا في المناطق المعرضه
للكوارث الطبيعيه وهو ما حدث في تركيا بعد
زلزال 1999 المدمر حيث فرضت السلطات
قانونا جديدا للمباني الجديده يلزم
بالامتثال لمعايير مقاومه الزلازل